hi Ben my name is you get labelled and
you're asking the question of what
leaders can do to deal with corruption I
think my first point is that they need
to adopt a zero tolerance to corruption
in their own company and to really work
with their staff so that the staff
understand what that means how they
relate to those who are trying to extort
money how they're able to sell better
without having to bribe and to make sure
that the incentives are right or the
company as well as the disincentive for
corruption and at the end the company
will be much better off we'll make as
much money if not more and there will be
a spirit of integrity throughout the
company and of course they need to deal
also their subsidiaries because they can
adopt themselves a zero tolerance to
corruption but they have to see that
their subsidiaries do the same